este es un ejemplo de la sesión de
ejercicios de khan academy sobre la
gráfica de soluciones de ecuaciones
lineales con dos variables nos piden
completar la tabla de manera que cada
renglón represente una solución de la
siguiente ecuación esta es la ecuación y
nos piden que encontremos el valor de g
cuando x es igual a menos 4 y el valor
de x cuando ya es 0 para resolver esto
copie y pegue este problema en mi
herramienta de dibujo
hay varias maneras en las que podemos
resolver esto una es tratar de
simplificar la ecuación dejando las x en
un lado y las leyes del otro lado o
podemos sustituir directamente las x y
las 10 en esta ecuación y así encontrar
los valores que nos piden hacemos
primero la segunda opción si tomamos
esta x este menos 4 y lo sustituimos que
vamos a encontrar
vamos a hacerlo tenemos entonces 2x + 3
igual a 5 x menos vamos a sustituir la x
menos 4 entonces vamos a tener 2 x x
cada que yo me encuentre una x la
reemplaza con el -4 2 x menos 4
3 igual a 5 x 5 x menos 4
menos
muy bien 2 x menos 4 es igual a menos 83
igual a 5 x menos cuatro menos veinte
menos que puedo sumar una y en ambos
lados de la ecuación y deshacerme de
esta menos entonces aquí sumo una y de
este lado también lo hago más y ahora
voy a sumar 8 positivo en ambos lados
para deshacerme de este menos 8 así que
aquí pongo más 8 y más 8
ahora qué es lo que nos va a quedar
bueno - yemas se cancelan justo por eso
puse esta más de aquí para deshacerme de
esta otra menos 20 más 8 va a ser igual
a menos 12 muy bien de este lado tengo
menos 88 se cancelan lo puse así esté
más 8 justo para deshacerme de este
menos 8 y aquí me queda tres más tres de
algo más uno de ese algo van a ser
cuatro de ese algo en este caso cuatro y
cuatro ya es igual a menos 12 y vamos a
dividir ambos lados de esta igualdad
entre 4 para dejar a nuestra y solita
así que nos queda que de 4 entre 4 es
igual a 1 es igual a menos 12 entre 43 y
es igual a menos 3 así que cuando x es
igual a menos 4 y es igual a menos 3
podemos incluso irlo poniendo en nuestra
página del ejercicio
aquí en lleva el -3 ahora nos queda
encontrar el valor de x cuando es cero
tomamos la misma ecuación pero ahora
sustituimos con cero vamos a hacerlo
esto entonces tengo la misma ecuación 2x
+ 3g y wallace 5x menos ya sustituyó
ahora todas las 10 con 0 aquí con este
me queda 2x más 3 por jet pero 10 0 3
por 0 es 0 + 0 igual a 5 x menos pero es
menos ser menos ser bueno lo pongo aquí
para que se note de dónde viene pero
realmente igual pude no haberlas escrito
muy bien entonces nos queda que 2x es
igual a 5 x restó 5x en ambos lados
porque quiero dejar las x en un solo
lado de la igualdad
entonces tengo aquí menos 5x igual a
menos 5x
esto a que es igual 5 x 5 x algo
arrestado ese mismo algo pues va a ser
cero y aquí tengo que 2 x 5 x es igual a
menos 3 x menos 3 x es igual a 0 y bueno
sí quiero dejar solita la x pues qué
puedo hacer puedes dividir ambos lados
entre menos 3 pero aquí como tengo un
cero pues va a ser lo mismo cero entre
algo va a seguir siendo cero de todas
maneras hago esta ecuación menos 3 entre
3 es igual a 1 me queda que x es igual a
0 cuando es igual a 0 x es igual a cero
bueno vamos a regresar al ejercicio en
la página web y ahora aquí pongo ser muy
bien
y nos dicen utiliza tus dos soluciones
estos dos puntos estos dos pares
ordenados para graficar la ecuación
vamos a ver la gráfica completa
tengo esta línea y esos puntos naranja
que son los que puedo mover entonces el
primer punto es menos cuatro menos 3 x
igual a menos 4 al voy a agarrar este x
es igual a menos 4 y ya es igual a menos
3 lo muevo aquí menos 3
esa es esta primera coordenada y la
siguiente es el origen x 0 10 en este
punto lo nuevo aquí al origen del plano
coordenada 00 y esta es la línea que
representa la ecuación que nos mostraron
esta ecuación de que todos los pares xx
se encuentran sobre esta línea van a
satisfacer esta ecuación
vamos a comprobar respuesta es correcta
pero dijimos que había dos formas de
resolver esto aquí lo resolvimos de la
manera más directa sustituyendo los
valores en la ecuación otra forma en que
pudimos resolverlo y la que yo creo es
la más sencilla es comenzar
simplificando esta ecuación y para esto
voy a poner todas mis x en un lado y
todas las 10 del otro lado voy a agarrar
otro color
voy a hacerlo de este lado entonces de
nuevo copio la ecuación 2x
3 igual a 5 x
menos
y quiero dejar mi siesta a la derecha y
las x a la izquierda
entonces si quiero quitar esta - tengo
que sumar más en ambos lados de la
ecuación así que aquí pongo más g y más
allá y si quiero dejar mis x de este
lado de la derecha quiero quitar este 2x
y aquí y pasarlo acá entonces tengo que
restar 2x en ambos lados
pongo aquí menos 2x y de este lado
también menos 2x y hago la operación
esto es igual
2 x 2 x 0 por eso lo puse lo quería
eliminar 13 + es igual a 4 y esto es
igual a 5 x menos dos equis es igual a
3x y menos massieu es 0 por eso lo puse
para cancelar me queda esto 4 y es igual
a 3x y puedo despejar y me quedaría que
dividido todo entre 4 esto entre 4 esto
entre 4 y me queda 4 entre 4 es 1 se
cancela esto me queda el ayer y me queda
aquí tres cuartos de x
de aquí representa a esta ecuación pero
está escrito de diferente manera esta
ecuación es lo mismo que esta otra solo
que están expresadas de diferente forma
todos los padres xy que satisfacen esta
ecuación van a satisfacer a esta otra y
viceversa pero esta forma es más
sencilla y aquí si x es igual a menos 4
lo sustituyó me queda que es igual a
tres cuartos de x que es menos 4 menos 4
con 4 se cancela y me queda que esto es
igual a menos 3 esto es 1 y aquí está el
signo negativo y es la que obtuve cuando
x es igual a menos 4 y es igual a menos
3 y cuando oye es igual a 0
aquí lo ponemos 0 que es igual a tres
cuartos de x pues x tiene que ser cero
para que esto se cumpla
tengo que multiplicar esto por ser así
que aquí
es igual a 0 como ven las cuentas aquí
son más sencillas comparadas con el
álgebra que tuvimos que hacer aquí que
fue un poquito más elaborado